Jessas, hallo ihr Lieben!
Wir sind gerade in Griechenland in Santorini, wir machen hier gerade unseren Jahresurlaub.
Und wir haben gedacht wir müssen für euch ein Video drehen!
Ich bin schon richtig eingefleischte Griechin hier!
Ich habe mir hier dieses Kleid heute aus einer Boutique gekauft
und jetzt mache ich mir Frappé und habe mir gedacht ich nehme euch da jetzt mal mit!
Also wir machen ja hier für 7 Tage Urlaub. Wir zeigen euch gleich auch wie's draußen aussieht:
traumhaft! Also Santorini ist echt ein Ort, den können wir euch total empfehlen zum Entspannen,
zum Runterkommen, zum Sonne tanken, ne?
(H: M-hm!)
Und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal Frappé, das ist so ein bisschen -
(H: *mit stark gerolltem R* Frappé!)
Das ist so...
DAS Nationalgetränk der Griechen, glaube ich. Ich habe mich so ein bisschen auch gewundert,
ich habe ja den Dalgona Coffee gemacht und eigentlich waren die Griechen als erstes da.
Und der Dalgona Coffee wurde glaube ich von BTS glaube ich...
irgendeiner von BTS hat das mal getrunken und dann-
(H: Dieses- diese koreanischen Sänger?)
Ja, ich - also ich höre BTS total gerne, den Hamza muss ich noch dran gewöhnen!
So, ich habe jetzt hier Nescafé tatsächlich, das ist so typisch griechisch.
Nescafé und Zucker. Und das gebe ich jetzt hier in meine Schüssel.
Und eigentlich Leute gibt's dafür auch so einen extra Frappé Mixer, das sind diese-
diese Milchaufschäumer, die so per Hand gehen. Das habe ich aber nicht,
ich war sogar extra in der Stadt und habe gefragt und die meinten:
"Nein, gibt's hier nicht, haben wir nicht!"
(H: Du wolltest Griechisch reden -"Nein!")
Und jetzt gebe ich hier kaltes Wasser dazu. Auch ein Unterschied zum Dalgona Coffee,
da hatte ich ja heißes drin.
Ein bisschen, ich würde mal schätzen so 3 Esslöffel. Ich schreibe euch alles nochmal ganz genau in die Infobox
was ich hier genau reingetan habe und wie viel.
Und jetzt muss ich das mit dem guten alten Schneebesen machen
und das wird jetzt glaube ich so ein bisschen dauern.
(H: Ich muss sagen wir haben auch paar Sachen mitgenommen, ne?)
Jaa, ein paar Sachen haben wir auch mitgenommen  weil ich auch hier einen Kuchen backen werde
und zwar den... Porto...
Portokalopita?
(H: *lacht*)
Auf jeden Fall werde ich einen griechischen Orangenkuchen backen,
das seht ihr dann aber in meiner Instagram Story!
So und jetzt wird's laut, jetzt rühr' ich!
(H: Dann rühr mal schön du! Solange du rührst, gehe ich einmal raus und zeig was abgeht!)
Okay!
(H: *Spongebob-Stimme* 50.000 Jahre später!)
So, fertig!
Es muss so fest sein, guckt! Und jetzt gebe ich das in 2 Gläser.
Schön gleichmäßig verteilen: einen für Hamza, einen für mich.
(H: Uuuh!)
Uuuuh!
Das haben wir heute morgen noch auswärts bestellt, das war so lecker!
Besser als der Dalgona Coffee, ich sag euch auch nachher warum.
So und jetzt kommen da ganz ganz traditionell Eiswürfel rein
und das Ganze wird mit kaltem Wasser aufgegossen.
Jetzt zum Vergleich der Dalgona Coffee: da war ja erst mal 80% Milch und oben nur dieser Schaum
und irgendwie... ja, war der nicht so geil! Aber diesen Frappé finde ich hingegen richtig richtig gut.
Und da kann man auch selbst bestimmen, wie viel Zucker man möchte. Auch wenn man bestellt hier
dann fragen die immer: "Möchten sie viel Zucker, wenig? Mit Milch oder ohnich- äh, ohne!
Richtig cool.
Und so ist der jetzt eigentlich schon fertig aber man hat halt die Option, noch Milch mit dazu zu nehmen
und Hamza ich glaube wir zwei sind Milch Fans, oder?
(H: Ja, auf jeden Fall!)
Okay, wir nehmen da jetzt noch einen Schuss Milch mit rein. Und nicht wie gesagt wie beim Dalgona Coffee
jetzt mega viel reinhauen, sondern eigentlich echt nur so einen Schuss
und dann kann man das noch richtig schön kalt genießen.
(H: Ja sach an, komm!)
So!
(H: Klatsch die Milch rein, du!)
So! *lacht*
Und fertig. Boah, das sieht so gut aus!
Perfekt für den Sommer, Leute!
(H: Ich würde mal sagen jetzt kommen die Shots!)
(H: Also nicht die "Shots" Shots, Alkohol Shots sondern die Kamera Shots!)
Die Kamera Shots!
(H: Guck mal, der will auch mit uns essen Kiki!)
Trinken!
(H: Ah trinken, sorry!)
Und wir lassen euch noch ganz viele liebe Urlaubsgrüße da!
Wir hatten diese 7 Tage einfach so nötig! Ich habe mit Hamza auch schon drüber gesprochen:
Wir haben in den letzten 12 Monaten einfach so viel Gas gegeben, wir sind so gewachsen.
Das freut mich ja extrem aber andererseits
- das ist das was man eigentlich auf Youtube und auf Instagram nicht sieht -
wir haben so einen Druck auf unseren Schultern weil wir haben in der letzten Zeit 20 Mitarbeiter
zusätzlich eingestellt. Die wollen am Ende des Monats alle ihren Kühlschrank füllen,
da haben wir so eine gewisse Verantwortung.
Und wir haben gedacht: "Okay, jetzt einmal kurz die Reißleine ziehen, kurz abschalten für 7 Tage."
Und wenn wir zurückkommen, dann werden neue Projekte angegangen,
dann wird wieder ordentlich Gas gegeben!
Und deshalb haben wir gedacht-
(H: Und auch Videos gedreht!)
Und auch Videos gedreht regelmäßig.
(H: Neue Rezepte!)
Genau, neue tolle Rezepte für euch! Und wir brauchten das jetzt einfach.
Und daher euch noch einen wunderschönen Tag, eine wunderschöne Zeit im sonnigen Deutschland.
Und bis Sonntag, dann kommt nämlich mein neues Video online!
Bis bald! Tschüss, eure Kiki!
(H: Euer Hamza!)
Das war